RUWEN HESS: Hello, and
welcome to the session,
Best Practices for Block
Storage on Google Cloud.
My name's Ruwen Hess,
and I'm a product manager
on Compute Engine Team.
And today, I have some
exciting new developments
on block storage
to share with you.
Before we jump in, I have a
short safe harbor statement.
The purpose of this presentation
is to provide better visibility
into our current product
plans and contains
forward-looking statements.
While we strive to meet
the timelines you will see,
this is not an
official commitment,
but our current best estimate.
Products on our roadmap and
any products in early release
are not guaranteed to
become generally available,
or may be significantly modified
from their current form.
In this session, we'll see
an overview of block storage
on Google Cloud with details
of what is new this year.
We cover available
disk types and discuss
how the new disk types fit
into the product family.
We then dive deeper into
how to select the right disk
types for your workloads to
better optimize performance
and cost.
Finally, we'll
cover some details
of how throttling
and performance works
for block storage, ending with
some simple best practices.
This year, we're expanding
our Persistent Disk product
portfolio with two new desktops.
Balanced PD is our general
purpose disk, best suited
for enterprise applications.
And for the highest
performance workloads,
such as SAP HANA and other
high-end in-memory databases,
we're introducing Extreme PD.
At the same time, all of
our existing disk types
are seeing substantial increases
in performance this year.
We have increased the
maximum sustained read IOPS
for zonal SSD persistent disks.
You can now issue 100,000 IOPS
per second, up from 60,000
previously.
IOPS-sensitive workloads
should see substantial benefits
from this increase.
We've also increased the
maximum sustained throughput
for zonal persistent disks
from 1,200 megabytes reads
and 400 megabytes writes.
Five times the sustained
lead throughput
enables cost-effective
implementation
of large scale throughput
intensive workloads,
such as Hadoop.
Some workloads are
optimized for TCO.
Others need every bit of
performance they can get.
Google Compute Engine now offers
a wider spectrum of disk types
to match your workload
needs, providing you
with the same flexibility that
our VM families already offer.
With the new disk
types, you can pick
the right price/performance
profile for your workload
storage needs.
Let's look at some of these
changes a little more closely.
Generally available
this month, Balanced PD
is our new general purpose
disk for Google Compute Engine.
It offers SSD performance
and represents an over 40%
saving compared
to Performance PD,
offering the lowest TCO for
general purpose workloads.
Balanced PD has the
right performance
for most enterprise
apps, web servers,
and even some small
and medium databases.
It also offers many of
the same advanced features
you already know
from Performance PD.
You can create regional
or zonal volumes,
and you can attach
multiple instances
to a single volume
in beat-only mode.
Balanced PD replaces Standard PD
as a new general purpose disk,
with six IOPS per gigabyte and
a maximum of 80,000 sustained
IOPS, it offers significantly
higher performance
and more performance per dollar.
In fact, whether write-heavy,
read-heavy, or in-between,
Balanced PD offers
two times the IOPS
per dollar for most
use cases or better.
This means that despite the
higher cost per gigabyte,
for many workloads, Balanced
PD can actually to improve TCO
when you take into account
the impact of faster
performance at the
workload level end to end.
This can express itself in
the form of cost savings
from faster task completion.
For example, reduced Dataproc
costs, or in the reduced need
to size to IOPS rather
than pure capacity.
Performance PD is our
new name for PD-SSD,
as it continues to
evolve and focus
on performance-sensitive
workloads.
This year, we have already
increased read IOPS
from 60,000 to 100,000.
And this month, we
are following this up
by increasing write IOPS
for zonal Performance PD
from 30,000 to 100,000 as well.
Similarly, this
month we are also
increasing write throughput
from 800 to 1,200 megabytes
per second.
And so zonal Performance PD
will have full read/write parody
coming forward.
Customers running databases
with write-heavy workloads
should see noticeable
improvements in performance,
from a three-fold
increase in write IOPS
and 50% improvement
in write throughput.
And Performance PD continues to
have the best price per IOPS.
We will also continue to
add more advanced features
to Performance PD.
And so in 2021, in addition
to the existing multi-reader
feature, we will offer
a multi-writer feature
on this disk type.
We expect to have this ready
for preview later this year.
For use cases that need
more IOPS or more throughput
than Performance PD offers,
we're introducing Extreme PD.
Extreme PD is our
new disk type for
high-end performance-critical
applications.
It has been designed
with SAP HANA
and other high-end
in-memory databases in mind.
At launch, it will offer
120,000 provisioned IOPS and 2.4
gigabytes a second of
maximum sustained throughput.
Extreme PD introduces
provision IOPS,
allowing you to provision
capacity and performance
separately.
Provisioned IOPS are
specified at disk creation
and then can be changed
dynamically at any time,
allowing you to adjust
disk performance
to the specific requirements
of your workload over time.
Next year, there will also
be explicit performance SLAs
for provisioned IOPS.
Extreme PD is preview
available this month,
and general
availability is expected
to follow in the third quarter.
Finally, we've also continued
to improve local SSD.
Local SSD now offers more
than three times the IOPS--
2.4 million read and
1.2 million write IOPS.
And local SSD now supports 9
terabytes, a threefold increase
in maximum capacity.
For Flash-optimized databases,
performance-sensitive
analytics, or hot
caches, Local SSD
now offers industry-leading
performance
per dollar for local storage.
With a new disk type
and improved performance
for existing disk
types, you can pick
the right price/performance
profile for your workload.
Let's have a quick look at
choosing the right disk type.
For many workloads,
three criteria
help to quickly identify
a good starting point
for the right disk type.
Firstly, what does the
price/performance profile look
like?
What are your workload's I/O
and throughput requirements?
How sensitive is the workload
to storage, scale, and cost?
Second, what are the
availability and durability
requirements?
If the workload is replicating
data across instances,
is this being handled
at the app, database,
or storage layer?
Finally, what storage
capacity will be needed?
Looking at performance
in a bit more detail,
the right price and right
price/performance by workload
depends on the disk type.
The exact performance
requirements
will, of course, vary for
each specific workload.
But in general, the
type of workload
will be a good indicator
of which disk type is
likely to be a good fit.
Workloads that are
performance-critical,
that depend on the highest
available throughput
and/or IOPS and need
durability are likely
best served by Extreme PD.
An example of this might
be in-memory databases.
IOPS-driven
performance-sensitive workloads
like most larger databases are
a good fit for Performance PD.
Performance PD offers
the best price per IOPS.
Balanced PD offers substantially
lower TCO than performance PD,
and offers the right performance
for web serving, line
of business, and IT apps.
Finally, Standard PD
is like a good fit
for throughput-oriented,
cost-sensitive workloads
with substantial
capacity requirements
such as, for example,
Hadoop or Kafka.
Similarly, durability and
availability requirements
will vary by workload.
As it is ephemeral, Local
SSD is a good option
for stateless workloads
where replication is managed
at the app or database layer.
Zonal Persistent Disk
is, of course, durable.
It also supports
snapshots, which
can be saved to a different
region for geo-redundancy.
For mission-critical
workloads that
need to meet very low recovery
point objectives and recovery
time objectives,
Regional Persistent Disk
provides a highly
available option.
Regional PD offers RPO for
single failures and RTO
less than a minute
at a disk level.
Of course, the
storage requirements
may not apply uniformly
to entire workloads.
Sometimes different
needs within a workload
are best met by
different disk types.
For example, for a
SQL server instance
you might leverage the
higher IOPS, lower latency,
and lower cost of local
SSD for a temp DB, which
doesn't need to be
persistent, and have
the data on a Performance
or even Extreme PD.
For an analytics pipeline, you
might have source and output
data on the Google
Cloud Storage,
while the intermediate
data that's
produced by one stage
of your pipeline
and consumed by another might be
in Persistent Disk or Local SSD
to achieve higher performance.
Using different disk
types with an instance
has interesting
performance implications.
Let's have a look at
understanding disk performance
in a bit more detail.
Persistent Disk
performance depends
on disk type, disk size,
instance type and size.
In this example, I have
an N2 standard instance
with 64 vCPU that can support
a maximum of 100,000 IOPS.
A Performance PD volume
is sized to 3 terabytes.
And at 30 IOPS per gigabyte,
that results in 90,000 IOPS.
If my workload benefits
from having access
to the full 100,000
IOPS, I could get there
by increasing the size of
the volume correspondingly.
On the other hand, if I
were to create a Balanced
PD of the same size instead, the
volume would have 18,000 IOPS.
For some existing
workloads, disks
are sized to each IOPS
requirements, versus fulfilling
capacity needs.
For these workloads,
especially if they
aren't PD standard disks, the
introduction of Balanced PD
might change the equation.
Throughput for Performance PD
and Balanced PD is full duplex.
Workloads can use
1,200 megabytes read
and 1,200 megabytes
write concurrently.
On the other hand, IOPS
pull from the same budget.
So read IOPS plus write IOPS
hit the same 100,000 or 80,000
limit for Performance PD or
Balanced PD, respectively.
Disks of the same type
count by total capacity
regardless of volume.
One disk of 3
terabyte or two disks
of the same total capacity
behave the same way.
In this example, my two disks
add up to the same capacity
that I previously
provisioned, and I've
continued to have 90,000 IOPS.
Under contention, the
IOPS are split evenly
across the volumes,
regardless of size.
If your workload has specific
requirements for subcomponents
or tasks, control
the IOPS consumption
at the workload level.
PD disks of different types
consume the same instance level
IOPS and throughput budget.
In this example, I've
added a Standard PD disk
to the instance.
And now I have to
watch for smaller jobs
and PD standard consuming
IOPS or throughput
during spikes for the
Performance PD-bound workload.
Local SSD and Persistent Disk do
not share in IOPS or throughput
limit.
Let's have a look at some
best practices and pitfalls
that we commonly see.
Disks smaller than 500
gigabytes have a boost feature.
This allows them to
boost the performance
to that of a 500 gigabyte drive
for short periods of time.
For the most
predictable performance,
size disks to be at
least 500 gigabytes.
In larger scale at workloads
and in some workloads that
migrated from
on-premise, we sometimes
see Persistent Disk use
as if it weren't durable.
In other words,
workloads sometimes
rebuilt data disks for nodes
after instance or node failure.
And in these cases, seeing
if rebuilding the data disk
is really needed might result
in substantial performance
improvements.
For large nodes, this
can turn minutes or even
hours of recreating data disks
into seconds of reattaching
to the existing disk.
As we just learned,
Local SSD instance limits
are separate from Persistent
Disk instance limits.
Pairing it up allows PD to
achieve higher performance.
For example, using local
SSD as scratch space
can move IOPS from PD volumes
hitting instance IOPS limits.
Or run the workload in Local SSD
with a replica or backup in PD.
Finally, I want to cover peak
versus average performance
and throttling.
Workloads with spikes,
we'll see throttled IOPS
and/or bytes even while
average performance is not
hitting the maximum of
the instance or volume.
You'll see this by average
meters showing performance
below what you would
see as a maximum,
but potentially peak showing
values that are much higher.
This is because average meters
cover 1 minute intervals,
while peak is a
point-in-time measure.
What this means is that
for these workloads,
there are often
two different ways
of achieving better performance.
You could increase the
IOPS for the volume,
for example, by
changing capacity,
disk type, or instance type.
Or it might be
possible to smooth out
the spikes of requests
coming from the workload.
If feasible, the latter can
achieve the same end result
without increasing
the resources required
and, hence, the TCO
of the workload.
And that concludes
our session today
covering Best Practices for
Block Storage on Google Cloud.
With Balanced PD
and Extreme PD, we
have introduced two new disk
types that fundamentally change
the price/performance
profile for general purpose
and performance-critical
workloads respectively.
And together with the
substantial improvements
in performance with
existing disk types,
you can now pick the right
disk for your workload,
matching the
flexibility you already
had with our VM families.
Thank you.